every now and again things kind of get
pushed out there enough and this is
largely because of you guys because of
people online that keep talking about
things and then eventually even the
corporate press has to roughly respond
to things in an honest way here is CBS
that's right CBS actually reporting on
the hunter Biden Crime Story I think
this is yesterday
if this was any other person they'd like
would have already served their sentence
Gary shapley was a lead IRS supervisory
agent in operation Sportsman the
investigation into Hunter Biden shapley
said he uncovered conduct that warranted
more serious charges there were personal
expenses that were taken as business
expenses prostitutes sex club
memberships hotel rooms for purported
drug dealers how much did Hunter Biden
Owen taxes so from 2014 to 2019 it was
2.2 million dollars the back taxes were
paid off and last week the Trump
appointed U.S attorney in Delaware David
Weiss reached an agreement with Hunter
Biden the president's son would admit to
a firearm charge and plead guilty for
his failure to pay taxes if a judge
signs off the deal means no jail time
okay so I want to give CBS a little
credit for actually airing anything
related to this talking to The
Whistleblower asking him his story so
that that is worth noting of course now
there's a couple things here first off
the fact that this guy owed 2.2 million
in taxes over these couple years again
what was his job and how did he get this
job he was a drug and sex addict who was
smoking crack out of carpet with a bunch
of what seemingly now our underage
prostitutes will probably find out more
on that and he had a job at a Ukrainian
Energy company for 83 Grand a month who
having no experience in that field so
who paid off the money where did the 2.2
million come from how much more did he
have beyond that there's there's so many
other questions here but yes they did
let him off the hook with the federal
tax evasion in essence again Ask Wesley
Snipes what he thinks about that Greg
price who's a journalist had an
interesting tweet about or it's a meme
really about this this is how the news
cycle goes it's not happening it's a
right-wing conspiracy theory it might be
happening it is happening and it's good
and then you just rinse and repeat I
thought that was a pretty sort of
perfect version of the circular lunacy
that we're dealing with with all of this
[Music]
foreign